Android
Performance Patterns
For mobile applications,
serialized data is a large and
constant chunk of information
that you have to pull
down from your servers.
But did you know
that the ordering
of the data inside
your serialized form
can have a huge impact
on its resulting size?
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And when it comes
to serialized data,
it might be worthwhile to
kick your object oriented
standards to the
curb for something
a little more powerful.
See most folks
organize their data
in memory as objects full of
numbers and functions and all
the other stuff.
Serializing arrays
of those objects
preserves their structure in
the resulting data stream.
This kind of
organization is what
we call an array
of structs form,
or array of objects or
classes or whatever language
you want to call it.
The gist is that the
serialized format
mirrors the in-memory
object oriented layout
of the data, which is convenient
from a programming perspective
but actually ends up bloating
your serialized stream.
Firstly, consider that
in the serialized form,
each member value must generally
be declared with its property
name.
Meaning that for each
instance of your class,
every property will have the
full property name as well as
the value declared in
the serialized file.
So obviously your
files going to be
larger as a result of all
these redundant property
names just sitting around.
Secondly, you need to
understand that this
is the worst possible data
layout for applying compression
to your serialized file.
Consider GZIP compression,
which is standard for most HTTP
responses.
GZIP compresses data by finding
duplicate strings in your file,
as long as they're within
a window of 32k characters
from each other.
So the larger your
serialized class is,
the further away
similar data types
are, meaning that there's
less duplicating inside
of that 32k window resulting
in less compression savings.
In general, using the
array of structs form
creates larger serialized files
that don't really compress
as well as they should.
So what's the solution?
The Struct-of-Arrays form.
Basically, think
of Struct-of-Arrays
as a transpose on your data.
Given a list of objects,
take all of one property
from every element, enlist them
together in their own array.
And then do this for each
property in the class.
For example, make an array
for just the width values
and a separate array
for the height values.
The serialized result of
this produces simple arrays
of similar typed data.
And when it comes
to serialization,
this format has some
immediate benefits.
Firstly, it removes the
redundant property names
from the serialized format.
Basically, they
all get collapsed
into a single instance.
So already, you're going
to be producing a smaller
serialized file.
Secondly, similar data
types are now contiguous,
meaning that the
GZIP algorithm is
going to have a better shot
at finding duplicate matches,
since duplicates are now going
to be closer together and more
likely to exist
in the 32k window.
And thirdly, organizing
your data in this form
helps you actually separate
out content for different types
of compression.
For example, if you have
an array of 1,000 numbers,
chances are GZIP isn't going to
do much with that information.
But it's better for you
to apply delta compression
to that stream of numbers
before throwing it
into the serialized file.
This is something
you really couldn't
do in the array of structs
form due to the complexities
of the object oriented layout
that is inherent there.
Now it's worth putting
out that once you've
transposed your
data, you can get
even better compression
and faster serialization
by adopting binary serialization
formats like protobuffs,
nanobuffs, or FlatBuffers.
These formats produce
much smaller files
than JSON or XML counterparts.
And at the end of the day,
that's kind of what you want.
Right?
I mean, different
layers of awesome
that you can pile
on top of each other
to create the
smoothest app possible.
Which is why you should check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns videos.
And don't forget to join the
Google+ community for other
insights from other
great developers.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.